but again another thing with this  generation is we have less kids like  families are way smaller in this  generation and that's another reason  like it's linked to that but the reason  why there's less kids is be all right  there's less kids but there's not less  sex  because back in the day the more sex you  had the more children you had yeah but  now that's why you only had back in the  day you only had sex with one person  because you're gonna have kids with them  but now there's less kids there's more  sex because there's contraception and  that's what the men don't want so you  might say you know what they might want  me because I've not had no children but  you might have no children about 15  previous partners  and that's the difference